is close to 700 players playing today
go upstairs to the picture table and
you'll be playing with Magnus Carlson by
the way
um
this is a hand that's playable from any
position including under the gun expect
to see him open once again
from that
A Min race once again by Fort Berkeley
minray is just a hand ago
with the sevens and perhaps it's been
Ray so save them some chips because Bill
said waking up with the monster with the
Queens
I do not expect to see him just call
here he is in Middle position
I think he's just thinking about how
much the three bet or maybe has the
number
and raises it the six big blinds
and volunteer with the ace Queen now if
we didn't see Bill said three bet
perhaps we would see we'll do it
well it's looking down and he is in the
cut off
and thus fold
I would say the two options there would
be to uh poor bet or to fold the folding
is a safer one and oh my God we could
see some fireworks here at Magnus
Carlson with the Ace King suited now I
do expect to see a four bet
Carlson trying to keep his Poker Face on
and it does appear he has a very good
poker face and in addition to being one
of the best if not the best chess player
in the world
and we're betting it's a 20. that will
get four brick to quickly fold this nine
it's very disciplined didn't even need
to think about it
understanding that he was behind one of
those players
however
I don't expect Bill stat to pull up his
hand
I expect either him to peel but
optimally
five bet perhaps with a shove based on
the stack depths
certainly not going to fold
and if Stacks were shallower then I
would certainly expect sex to be in but
perhaps because of how deep players are
we will see some post-op play
gilstead is a very experienced player
let's see how he approaches the spot
against the chess Legend Magnus Crossing
facing a war bet
we haven't seen Carlson at all get out
of line
in the nearly two hours that he's been
at the feature table
so perhaps these are things going
through Bill said's Head
the two actually likely played at the
outer table together before hitting the
feature table on the break
I do like he's at least thinking
everything through
do not need to rush your decisions in
live poker
time bank would have ran out online
though it does just call
it's a very interesting here we'll be
playing in position with this Queens
pretty good flop for the Queens with the
two of diamonds three of Club Jack of
Spades I also I would have liked to say
something better
the cross Empire's out of continuation
but anyway
it does look like
he is thinking about it
gears are in motion
and he's reaching for some chips
but it wasn't a very large bet I don't
believe it's 7 000 into a pot of forty
four thousand eight hundred
perhaps doing that to make sure he's
getting his price on the Flop hoping for
something
else on the Turner River or just to see
where he's at but I don't think he's
going to get much information if bill
sent his claws but I don't think Bill
Stein should just call
so let's see what Oscar does here that
does look like
indeed a call
so Carlson's setting the price Bill said
just calling and Carlson improving to
top pair on the King of Clubs turn
yeah
Bill said by not by bet jamming prefab
by not racing the Flop although it would
be racist big you probably would have
gone across another way perhaps we'll
save himself some chips
are also despite improving the top hair
does check this time around
and feel sad although it's just one over
card that King Eclipse does kind of hit
Carlson's range of four betting there's
a lot of Ace Kings like he has in that
range it's also Kings and Aces I went
Crossing poor betting light at least
at this point in time based on what
we've seen from him thus far in the
event and the private space complete
support on the river Carlson with the
check mark
in an amazing spot to gain some chips
it's already almost 60 000 in the pot
after it went check check on the turn
I think we'll see Carlson try to get a
little more value
from the river
and that's one third of the pot give or
take with a bet of eighteen thousand
this mainstream Bill status long
although we should be confident that his
hand is good he knows he has very strong
Showdown value
it's good once again that we see Bill
said thinking things over
rather than rushing his decisions
like we see many players do in my poker
and on my bookie are forced to make fast
decisions
and live poker you can take your time
usually have at least two three minutes
before a player will call a
especially
on a riverbed
so you should take your time
go back through the hand
back through your opponent
and then make your decision
perhaps he would try to get a read off
your opponent but that's going to be
hard
with Magnus Carlson
it does call only to get the bad news
that he was ahead until the turn Magnus
Carlson picking up the pot is up to 159
000 in chips
meanwhile Oscar Bill said has seen his
opening stock of 100 000 dwindled to
just 41 000 still some hope
we have a break approaching soon but